cook shanks will they understand it's my
favorite book in the series is on My
Fair movie yes everybody it's true the
patreon sponsored revisit of the Harry
Potter films continues as we reach Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban it is
my favorite book in the series and
as I mentioned in the intro it's done my
favorite movie this one's gonna be
interesting I'm gonna have to be very
careful how I explain myself because
I've seen I mean this one gets highly
praised a lot and I've seen people claim
it's the not only the best and the
franchise I've seen some people claim
it's the only actual great movie in the
series and it is significantly better
than either the first or the second one
on pretty much every level on a
technical level on a on a adaptation
level on a performance level on a visual
and effects level it's loads better than
either chamber of secrets or
philosopher's stone or Sorcerer's Stone
was but I still have some notable issues
with it some of which are not the fault
of the film and there was really no way
around but I'll get to those because
let's start with what's good about this
well we have our first director
changeover and let's be blunt about
Alfonso Cuaron is a much better
filmmaker than Christopher Columbus's
that's it's as simple as that Chris
Columbus is a director who just shoots
the script you give him he is a
competent filmmaker but he doesn't bring
a lot of his own flavor to it
Alfonso
or on on the other hand definitely
brings his own feel his own flavor he's
doing his own thing and not just in
terms of the visuals like there were
things added into this that are
completely his idea the shrunken heads
those aren't in the book that's just him
and it's those sorts of touches and the
whole feel of it is very different
whereas the first two thoughts had a
very high degree of reverence for the
entire Wizarding World which honestly
that's not even necessarily a knock
against those it made sense especially
for the stories that were more
introducing these this it's all much
more casual there isn't the sense of awe
around every single thing that's magic
the world feels a little bit dirtier a
little bit grayer a little bit more
lived-in it's less like this magical
theme park that Harry goes to and more
like oh it's a place where people just
live and act and yeah they do magic but
like just just going through our day
over here it's a bit honestly and I
don't know if this will make sense
anybody it made me think a little bit
about the Addams Family in terms of like
yes all of this is weird
but for these people it's their normal
so presenting it much more that way I
think is a nice progression and we have
little touches like the kids wearing
normal standard clothes when they aren't
in class and that makes a lot of sense
and again it adds that more laid-back
feel to it we have Michael Gambon for
his first outing as Dumbledore which
honestly I'm slightly mixed on he's not
bad but the sense I get watching this is
that the both the writer and the
director didn't know how Gambon was
going to approach this differently from
how Richard Harris did it I think that's
especially true of the writing because I
think of when the students all have to
sleep in the Great Hall and Dumbledore
walks through and he's talking with I
believe Snape and he stops over Harry
and he has this sort of protracted for
in dreams we enter a world that is
completely of our imagination something
the the line feels like it was written
for the way Richard Harris played the
character because I can hear not that
gamblin is trying to read it like
Richard Harris but I can hear that
little bit be said by Harris much better
than it sounds being sent by Gambon and
I just feel like they hadn't fully
climate adieu ways in which his
Dumbledore was different and I feel like
they had figured that out by his later
appearances whereas here we're in this
weird slight transitional phase where we
have now the new actor playing
Dumbledore but they're still writing it
for the old actor if that makes any
sense and part of the reason I feel
confident in sort of saying that it's
not quite clicking it is because it
clicks much better in subsequent films
here it is just slightly off not bad but
slightly off we're in a transitional bit
on it there the kids are great like all
the kids are really coming into their
own as actors at this point Tom felt and
honestly especially is really finding a
good way to continue being the bully
jerk that Draco Malfoy is while also
sort of making it feel more like a real
person and less like just an absolute
archetype Oh tosser
you know with that that sneer and
everything else which again that's not a
knock on his performance in the first
who those absolutely worked but here
he's able to still accomplish that while
feeling slightly more naturalistic and
slightly more believable which is all
really good we've got some really strong
new performances in here as well because
we have Gary Oldman coming in as Sirius
Black who's quite good we have David
Thewlis coming in as Lupin he's a great
flying through this is an interesting
actor and he he's in he makes
interesting choices for what movies he's
in and he doesn't always work but he was
a good solid pick for this one he he
works quite well the Dementors I was
actually really pleased I remember very
first time going to the theatre how
pleased I was with the design on them
because how they're described in the
book it would have been really easy
basically just have them be the Nazz
goals from from Lord of the Rings but
they found a way to to have to have them
appear that felt very true to the book
but was altered just enough to to not
feel derivative which it very easily
could have been that would have been a
big mistake given our recently Lord of
the Rings had come out for when this
this this particular intrigue and the
series came through there is one
performance that doesn't quite work for
me and that is Timothy Spall as Peter
Pettigrew as Wormtail I he's not bad but
I think about him the same thing that I
think about what I said about Moaning
Myrtle when I talked about chamber of
secrets which is that his style of
acting is hammy to the point that it
would have felt more appropriate in an
earlier entry but we're now
transitioning into a more naturalistic
style of performance for a lot of these
characters and he feels like he's still
doing a very over-the-top very a very
hammy performance which is not a bad
performance but it does feel a little
bit disconnected because it is certainly
compared to everybody else a bit over
the top and a bit much um coming back to
loop and real quick I do really like the
design of the werewolf it's all I'm like
it is kind of off-putting how spindly it
is and how there's really long limbs
it's an unusual design for a werewolf
and I really dig it I dig that that
design a lot and it was also interesting
watching this I really have my eye kind
of on the color because this is a much
more muted color palette than the
previous two films did which were very
bright and vibrant that first one
especially very bright very vibrant this
one's got a lot more gray going in it
but something that I found very
interesting was there were there would
be scenes where a lot of stuff was toned
down great but there be a couple of
things where the colour would pop not
like completely bright like it's not
like Sin City
like there's the one thing that's ran
against everything's like it's not quite
to that degree but it's the same kind of
principle like the the shop where I
really noticed it for the first time was
Harry riding Buckbeak and when they're
flying over the lake it's actually very
gray that shot except for the red on
Harry's gear on a descriptive thing like
his patching is tied that red is a
little bumped up again not so much as to
be like like the visual equivalent of a
clown nose but now for my oh that's kind
of interesting there so what I liked
about noticing that is it makes the sort
of grayer tones of the film feel well
more thought-out it wasn't just well
this one's more serious so it's just
gray like no we're gonna put thought
into this yes we'll be grave here but
let's have pops of color here here with
this this and this and like okay you put
thought into this and didn't just slap
an Instagram filter over it very cool um
but yeah I said I have some issues here
I mean like I mentioned a couple with
things like the the performance on
Wormtail the big one is a problem that
honestly couldn't really be helped and
that is that the structure of this story
flat out works better on the page than
it does on film it just does because the
thing climaxes with a lot of runtime
left because the emotional and narrative
climax proper of this thing is the
shrieking Shack and and lupins werewolf
transformation and escaping that
situation those scenes are the emotional
narrative you know climax there it's the
climax of basically everything that's
been going on it's the climax of the
mystery elements the action elements the
emotional elements everything culminates
right there but there's still like a
half hour forty minutes of the movie to
go because with the time-turner we have
to now tie up all the logistical stuff
that needs to be fixed because of the
time travel mechanisms
and the nature of film because film is a
very propellant medium it is a medium
with forward momentum by its very nature
because the film always keeps moving
forward you can have sort of
aggressively propelled narratives in
literature but it's not quite the same
cuz at any moment you can close the book
set it down and do something else
whereas a movie yet watching from home
you can pause and do something else but
I think we can all agree that the sort
of idealized experience of a movie is in
a theater where you don't have the
ability to pause it and you are on this
trip and as it is moving forward so when
the climax of most films happen the
thing then wraps up within 10 20 minutes
tops
of when the thing actually finishes and
the times that you find exceptions to
that are usually either examples where
something didn't quite work or it kind
of actually it's the exception that
proves the rule so like yes the post
climax there's a lot in Return of the
King but that's also wrapping up three
films or at the stuff a little bit
different or it's actually I think one
of the big problems with Christopher
Nolan's film interstellar the emotional
climax of the film is halfway through
and it never hits that peak again so I
think in general films there's a reason
most films wrap up fairly quickly after
they hit their climax but this one can't
because it's got so many narrative
threads that it has to tie together in
order for the thing to make any kind of
sense and that works in the book because
the narrative on the page in print does
not require and it does not have built
in the same forward momentum must always
keep moving forward so having it slowed
down and going for a longer stretch
after your actual climax you can get
away with in a book that and it doesn't
quite click in a film not to say that it
means the movie suddenly doesn't work
but it is one of those instances where
the differences in the medium actually
impact how well the story work
and I think for that reason primarily it
works much better on the page than it
does on the screen plus also if I'm
gonna cite one flat out miss like
bungling that the film does and this
isn't just like others performance a
little like not like how did nobody
catch this they do none of the work
needed in order for Harry's belief that
he was saved by his father to make any
sense at all
now obviously Harry's wrong he wasn't
saved by his father who saved by himself
looping back with all the time Turner
but they cut all of the details that
would have it make any sense that he
would have ever thought that in the
first place now the book has the
advantage that we are actually privy to
Harry's thought process in a way that we
aren't in the movies because even though
it's not first-person narrative the
books are practically from Harry's
perspective we are privy to his thought
processes and so we understand the exact
series of things that he sees and thinks
that causes him to believe that but
because we don't have access to his
thought process the film failed to lay
out the things that caused him to think
that such as establishing a that his
father's Patronus was a stag I mean we
have the thing you know Moony Wormtail
Padfoot and prongs the movie does not
explain who those are does not make it
explicit does not explain that Harry's
dad James was proms that he was an
animagus that he had that I think he was
an animagus it's been a while since I
read the book but at the very minimum
that that a that a stag was his Patronus
and this one I really can't like every
time I go back and re-watch this I'm
like am I crazy that they blew this I'm
like no they really did and nobody ever
calls it out which I never get when we
see the Dementors shoot away for the
first time by the Patronus charm you
know we're
Harry singing he thinks this is dad and
he passes out we don't see the stag that
first time it's just a white glow and a
figure there's no stag we only see the
stag the second time when Harry actually
does it for real which again makes no
sense because a it's inconsistent it
doesn't look the same both times and be
you needed it to be there granted they
failed to establish what the stag meant
but you needed it to be there to again
to have the idea that Harry thought this
was his dad make any sense at all the
only thing I can think of that I'd never
see anybody call this movie out for this
is that basically everyone I know who's
seen this movie has also read the books
so they know what this means even though
they fail to recognize that the film is
not built in a way that you could
possibly understand exactly what this
moment is doing unless you've also read
the book which is really irritating
because these films for the most part
while very good and very faithful
adaptations have been made accessible
and they can make sense even if you
haven't read the book but this moment
doesn't it doesn't make sense because
they don't explain the things that need
to be explained and I understand why
Harry would have ever thought that that
was his father
so Harry sounds insane when he says I
saw my dad my dad saved me because we
have no reason to understand why he
thought that that drives me absolutely
up the wall and granted it's one element
it's one scene but again it's part of
the climax and it's part of the rap it's
part of the wrap-up after the climax
where again I talked about the
structural issues not really way around
that
I don't think anyways but like how like
how did that how did it happen and how
does nobody ever get annoyed by this how
am I the only one I did I don't know
and also I'm very sorry but stopping on
a freeze-frame of Harry zooming off
is dumb and cheesy and very 90s sitcom
it just is but again this movie is very
good it is a better film better shot
that are acted better presented and in
terms of actually adapting the narrative
to be something that is representative
of the original work while still you
know being a little bit of his own thing
is a better adaptation than the previous
to work at least by my measure of what
makes a good adaptation because some
people say you're good adaptation is
exactly the source material and I don't
subscribe to that policy but even though
I do believe that this is a better film
than the previous two I've got
significant issues with this thing so I
hope I have articulated them well
because I know this one really does feel
like it's a lot of people's favorite
film in the series and again it's my
favorite book in the series so I get it
I do but yeah there's some hiccups in
this thing Harry Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban there's a lot of stuff I
didn't get to a lot of stuff I didn't
talk about a lot of great performances
this is where I really started to fall
in love with Fred and George there's
just so much great stuff and the rapport
between all the characters and and like
the world it just feels more like a
place where people live as opposed to
just come and visit and that's great but
yeah these little hair cups person or
Azkaban have you seen it what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about their stuff too new
down there as well you can support me on
patreon which helps make the channel
better helps do things like upgrade my
equipment and and just help me cover my
bills if I'm being honest plus you can
subscribe like both of those are very
helpful as well there's other links
besides click on them bill thank you
places or don't you don't have to
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meanings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
Oh like random thing could they decide
they're expelling Armas knocks people
back or not because it gets used three
times in a row first time it just knocks
out the one next time it shoots the
person completely back next time it just
knocks out the wand out of their hand
again and I just drop mine like just aa
tiny careless things in another wise a
great movie anyway I'm done I swear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]